Congress goes back to work Monday after
a two-week recess some Republicans who
returned to their districts avoided
tough questions from constituents but
not congressman Bradley Byrne the
Alabama lawmaker held eleven town halls
in four days he drove himself and his
staff across rural Alabama where he
fielded concerns about the Trump
administration's plans chief
congressional correspondent Nancy Cordes
joined burned for an all-day ride along
and she's in Mobile yet say good morning
good morning you can see why some
Republicans might not want to hold so
many town halls after some of the anger
that they've been faced with this year
but congressman Bern believes that the
antidote to all that conversation is
more conversation and he took us on a
120 mile journey to explain why thank
you so much for letting us spend the day
with you Bradley Bern does more town
halls than nearly anyone in Congress 87
of them since he began representing
Alabama's first district in 2013 are
there more people that are turning out
this year who are more adversarial to me
about my positions yeah and some of them
state their position is pretty darn
forcefully that's America that's good
hey there good to see you our first stop
is excel Alabama population 700 well
this is my ninth Town Hall this week the
president is a prime topic will you
promise us that you will steer away from
what is a lot of inflammatory rhetoric
yeah okay I like that policy you will
yeah
president Trump won Alabama by 28 points
so there are plenty of supporters here
too
the press is trying to get things that
everybody loves burns next stop is a
Senior Center in Grove Hill I'm very
concerned about the lighting on US
Highway 43 where he fields questions
about infrastructure drugs veterans and
the budget what are we gonna do about
this expensive wall but here and
everywhere really don't repeal and
replace health care comes up again and
again but I have heard from a large
number of people in my district that
they have been hurt by the Affordable
Care Act good to see you unlike some of
his colleagues Ron does not believe that
the Democrats challenging him at his
Town Hall are coming from out of state
they're all local people in some cases I
know them and know them pretty well I am
so very tired of racism his final stop
is half an hour away in Wagar Ville
because you're a congressman I mean
healthcare is not a concern for you yeah
I mean but not as it is to me Verne
tells him the GOP is Obamacare
replacement plan will be an improvement
the ACA insurance exchanges are
imploding did you hear anything today
that's gonna change the way that you
look at legislation that's before you
right now listen to what that young man
said at the very end there what are
y'all going to get to work okay I think
that was probably the strongest message
I heard all day let's get to work
congressman Bern told his constituents
he's skeptical about talk of consensus
growing around a new version of the
Republican plan that would eliminate
some of those protections for people
with pre-existing conditions and Gale
pre-existing conditions was the number
one topic that we heard about from
constituents all day here yes I believe
that thank you very much Nancy
I admire congressman Bern not know not
only that he does so many that he does
but goes knowing that not he's not going
to hear great thing right
well as he says until I this is what
it's all about yeah conversation is
everything he is democracy in action
it's very nice Thank You Nancy